[Laughter]
I'm gonna catch up shit-shit the Duchy
now I want to turn up with you guys I
swear I know things
I'll take them to the captain CB sticks
right do that on your feet you you will
regret this
sure you did hey give me
in the early days right after the dollar
flute workout all attention and resource
was placed on containing the virus and
reducing the spread of infection the
infected were rounded up and isolated
into an area where the best doctors
could be brought in to find a cure but
also to stop the illness from dispersing
out into the wider population the
government placed absolute priority on
the well-being of the public and
ensuring that loss of life was kept to a
minimum however this is New York the
home of Wall Street the home of the
largest and most prestigious stock
market in the world the large Wall
Street companies also wanted to insure
that their assets are being protected
during the outbreak watching the
situation quickly escalate their
predicted that the government wasn't
going to be able to keep the peace for
long so they brought in some outside
help to defend their various corporate
interests and this is where we're
introduced to the last man battalion the
last man battalion or LMB are a private
military company made up of US military
veterans who were brought aboard by
their leader Charles bliss who himself
was a former US Army officer Charles
bliss was a lieutenant colonel in the
United States Armed Forces he was proud
of the uniform and he knew from the
moment that he first put it on that he
would continue to serve long after he
leaves the military behind Bliss leads
with an iron fist duty honor strength
these are just a few words that you
could use to describe his character he
is respected by his men who would follow
him to the gates of hell if he acid of
them after he retired from the Armed
Forces he decided to work in the private
security sector and this is where he
created the last man battalion in the
early days of the outbreak Bliss was
contacted by one of the corporate
leaders of Wall Street I records Charles
I got your message regarding the
situation in New York and I think you're
absolutely right things are going to get
out of hand faster than the government
realizes they're going to lose control
before they've even signed the
deployment orders yeah that's me the
only thing that's gonna work is to
impose absolute authority on the
population people are scared and angry
and that's when they'll act stupid and
risk the lives of others I've seen it
too many times now you want to shut
those instincts down and enforce zero
tolerance anything beyond that is not
going to produce results and
that will cost you a lot more than
hiring my people after convincing
several corporations to employ his
forces the LMB were deployed in
Manhattan with the goal of protecting
their physical assets by any means
necessary until the situation had been
resolved and the city was back to normal
as the crisis worsened many of these
companies left the city but the LMB
remained and continued to protect the
sites as time went by bliss earnest
forces saw the city go from bad to worse
sick of the indecisive local authorities
and the government's complete lack of
ability to control the situation bliss
was growing tired of standing by and
watching the city fall into complete
chaos by the time that the general
public realized that this was more than
just a bad flu outbreak bliss had come
to the conclusion that there was no
point in handing over his men's lives in
order to protect some physical assets
because of the rate things were going
there would be no one coming back to use
them after the JTF withdrew from the
city
let's decided that was up to the LMB to
restore order to New York relying on the
Joint Task Force right here in the
middle of Manhattan that's what they're
calling the dark zone that's a
melodramatic way of saying it's a region
of complete lawlessness no surveillance
and total lack of ability to enforce
control that is something you cannot
have in your watch so I thought the
purpose was to evacuate and how does
that work out sure they got the people
out but what did they let back in and
all the equipment and hardware they left
behind we're talking amateurs here in
charge of Public Safety and one of the
biggest cities in the country yes sir
the point is expansion civilian
processing enhanced interrogation while
working at twice the efficiency with
half the manpower the fact that the JTF
failed miserably with the dark drone is
the same reason the city needs the last
man battalion Lewisburg his contract
with his Wall Street employers and
proceeded to disobey direct orders which
ended up with him executing each ATF
official this action had bliss in his
entire company labeled as mutineers and
enemies of the government convinced that
not just New York but the whole country
will collapse under the spread of the
virus Bliss tells his people that the
LMB will use any and all means necessary
to make sure they and the city survived
but only a strong hand could salvage and
restore what was left
with the financial backing now gone list
would now have to assist the available
resources and plan every step of the way
what we need to do is assess our
resources and define our mission
statement the statement is clear we must
retake control and with the resources we
have left it's also clear we can't
afford any half-measures every soldier
counts every soldier is a critical
resource there are no reinforcements
being deployed there is no air support
we work slow and steady
we secure the city sector by sector and
then we hold them for dear life I need
you all to be in your feet ready to make
some quick decisions it's better to
shoot someone innocent than to let
someone guilty get away and it's better
to shoot first than to risk being shot
even if you're not sure that's how we
will win this war to be expected well
civilians lived in Manhattan this was a
nightmare the LMB were running the area
demanding absolute control with zero
tolerance for disobedience or differing
point of view any dissent or even
questioning of the lnbs operations would
result in instant retaliation with even
minor incidents resulting in death at
the hands of the lnb soldiers in an
attempt to keep numbers boosted the LMB
would often kidnap JTF and members of
other factions that they saw as
beneficial to their cause and give them
the Opera Theatre joining up or being
killed the LMB are equipped with
cutting-edge equipment and gear almost
at the same caliber as the division
agents but when Charles bliss agreed to
meet up with former first wave division
agent Erin keener Melissa's intentions
were to close this technology gap listen
kina came to an agreement
Erin keener is able to utilize the lmv
to run missions and bliss gets access to
key Nashik technology although he
accepts the alliance with Erin kina was
criticized how much this deal benefitted
Erin keener more than home in one of
their first missions kina gives the LMB
coordinates for their surface-to-air
missiles to strike I think we need to
modify the terms of our agreement why
this is working perfectly well so far
you get the support of my people
Hill didn't tell you couldn't rule of
six weeks ago I get a base of operations
a place um what's gonna be the winning
side not to mention the occasional
surface-to-air missile or have you
forgotten about that chopper in Brooklyn
look my people did the dirty work on
that op Bliss at eliminating divisions
senior command was as much a benefit to
you as to me the last thing either of us
wanted was a senior division agent
directing a second raven and not a girl
feedback on the link we've been
compromised looks like a guttural link
now now don't you
the target is a helicopter carrying the
second wave division commander along
with a number of other secret wave
agents it was a direct hit killing the
commander and a large number of the
second wave division agents keener and
the LMB have succeeded from their point
of view is safe to assume that they've
put it into any further interference
from the division as they're now
leaderless and fewer number it wasn't
until the division pick up an shd
transponder signal that the LMB would
next encounter the second wave agents
it was located in the basement of the
New York police academy the division
pushed through an operation to retrieve
the transponder and were met with heavy
resistance from the LMB
even with rogue agents in their ranks
the LMB failed to defend the site and at
the stage the division are now aware of
the first wave agents working for the
other side next the JTF intercepted a
signal coming from the Russian consulate
the tower Leaton enco a Russian
scientist claims to have information on
the green poison so the division agents
were quickly sent in to extract them
however keener and the LMB were one step
ahead while the division agents were
tied up with the lmp2 rogue agent sketch
of Vitaly and managed to escape in a
helicopter at this point the OMB has
started to suffer the communication hub
at Queens tunnel construction site was
taken down by the division and jtf and
the Grand Central Station which acted as
a strategic forward base also met an
abrupt end at the hands of the division
on top of that the amount of supplies
ammunition and manpower lost at these
sites are now starting to be felt
products trained on the remaining ellaby
forces listen the lmv have now been
pushed back to the main HQ the United
Nations building it's here that
alongside quinoa's rows that the LMB
will make their last stand
the JTF and the division launched a huge
attack the majority of the LMP are
killed in the UN building as the
division agents sweep through its then
discovered that kinara strokes have
abandoned the LM be taken to Nikko with
them after kena betrays him and leaves
the lnb for dead bliss is thrown into a
state of rage but he decided to deal
with the second wave agent storming the
General Assembly before going up to kena
verse displays his true self showing
loyalty and honor by staying by his men
and fighting to the death rather than
simply escaping from the complex in this
personal helicopter the division clears
the LMP command and then hits into
direct combat with the leader of the
last man battalion Bliss's helicopter
was shot down and destroyed killing plus
the remaining lnb personnel evacuated
the building most going into hiding in
the underground after Bliss's death the
LMB was scattered across the city but
they're not down and out yet captain
Perez takes position to continue Bliss's
work he rallies the remaining L&B forces
and hits to the warren gate water
treatment plant there they intercept a
JTF squad who have discovered a
functioning armored personnel carrier
news of this reached the government they
decided that the best course of action
would be to bomb the plant before the
LMB take it out onto the streets the
main agent the division disagreed saying
that loss of the water treatment plant
will only slow down the progress towards
rebuilding the city so the division
launched an attack against the LMB to
shut them down before the government can
blow up the building after a lengthy
some would say repetitive battle the
agents were successful in stopping the
LMB and taking down the APC with captain
Perez inside it's unknown who is leading
the LMB at the stage but they continue
to regroup and organize smaller attacks
around the city news of Aaron kinas
appearance on the West Side pier at the
lmv command calling for a truce with the
Rikers and cleanness their attention has
been turned to finding the man that
betrayed them and their former commander
though not all lmv personnel agree with
this move as they see their training and
discipline is far beyond the other
factions and that the Rikers and
cleaners are useless and a waste of time
but there is one thing that they do all
agree on that Kino must be found
although the LMB had good training
cutting-edge equipment military
precision and strong organization they
were still able to be pulled apart by
the division agents and the JTF things
started going wrong for them when some
of the basic foundations of their
organization started getting cut off
communication systems were destroyed
board strongholds lost and the supplies
were seized by government forces they
were eventually locked down in the
United Nations building and this was the
final nail in the coffin Hursley keener
abandoned them taking the rogue agents
and vitelli to Nikko with them and then
finally bliss refusing to leave his men
behind succumb to the JTF and the
division attack the LMB are not fully
done and dusted
even after Bliss's death they continued
to regroup and fight but now in a much
smaller less threatening scale the JTF
and division agents in new york city the
last man battalion was the last faction
capable of stopping them in their goal
of restoring order and rebuilding the
city but here's the funny thing when you
think about it the last man battalion
isn't so different to the division a
private army of highly skilled agents
answerable only to the President and
otherwise are above the law and power to
use lethal force to further their inns
sound familiar kind of makes you wonder
anyway thanks for watching I hope you've
enjoyed this and I'll see you in the
next one Cheers
from the first time I put on a uniform I
knew I was on the path to become the man
I was destined to be I knew I had
accepted a burden that was going to last
a lifetime and even when I left our
country's military behind my obligation
for service remained that obligation is
one I and all the men and women of the
last man battalion takes seriously we
will get the job done we will serve with
honor and dignity and we will if
necessary fight to the very last man
because that is who we are and what we
do the last man battalion security you
can count on
[Music]